[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the 2017 xbox III briefing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the head of Xbox
Phil Spencer
hey dump us up
okay good afternoon to those of you with
us here in person watching on this
incredible 4k screen to the millions
watching us around the world or TV
online and to those of you watching and
interacting on mixer on behalf of
everyone on Team Xbox welcome to e3 2017
when the renegade group of gamers
creators and engineers came together to
form the original Xbox team and deliver
the first Xbox console we were driven by
three principles empower developers
delight gamers and deliver true hardware
and technical innovation the original
Xbox team lived by the mantra there's no
power greater than X and today we are
pre proud to welcome the newest member
of the Xbox family fittingly named Xbox
1x
Xbox 1x the most powerful console ever
made sets a new quality standard for
gamers and game creators starting on
November 7th Xbox 1x joins the Xbox one
and the Xbox one s when it launches
worldwide now I'd like to introduce one
of our leaders in the Xbox engineering
team responsible for making the Xbox one
experience great for gamers and
developers please welcome my friend
Kareem Chowdhury to tell you more
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks ville it's an honor to be here at
e3 and represent three years of
engineering the team has done to bring
you Xbox 1x from the beginning
our focus on game creators and you the
gamer gave us three big goals we needed
to hit power compatibility and
craftsmanship let's talk power which
starts with the specs six teraflop GPU
clocked at one point one seven two
gigahertz twelve gigabytes of gddr5
memory and 326 gigabytes per second of
memory bandwidth these are impressive
numbers that are more powerful than any
other console on every dimension because
that's what it takes to give game
creators the power they need so you can
experience true 4k resolution 4k
textures and 4k assets in your living
room and when we say true 4k we mean 8
million pixels high dynamic range wide
color gamut premium sound like dolby
atmos and 4k UHD blu-ray playback
next compatibility we knew compatibility
was critically important for Xbox one X
and your reaction to 360 backward
compatibility is energize the team even
more so right from the start all of your
Xbox one accessories and games will work
with Xbox one X but for the team in me
that wasn't good enough we wanted more
the game library you have today will
look and play even better on Xbox one X
with enhanced visual fidelity
anisotropic filtering and faster load
times even if you haven't made the jump
to a 4k TV yet we designed this product
for you as well
since Xbox one X enables a technique
called super sampling the new 4k games
you see on stage today will look better
on your 1080p TV than anything you've
seen before and finally craftsmanship we
meticulously paid attention to every
detail of design as we crafted our most
technically advanced console ever it
starts with the Scorpio engine we use 16
nanometer technology to build a 360
square millimeter chip with seven
billion transistors and a 384 bit wide
memory bus this is the fastest most
advanced processor to ever power a
console our premium design means that
every millimeter and every component
within the console has been architected
for maximum power and efficiency our
aspirations were so high an industry
standard approach just wasn't good
enough
the Scorpio engine is so intense that
for the first time ever on a console
we're using a liquid cooled vapor
chamber normally reserved for servers
and high-end PC cards
an engineer on the Xbox hardware team
invented a new power management system
so innovative we named it after him the
Hovis method uniquely optimizes every
single Xbox one X at the system and
component level to deliver consistent
performance efficiently and elegantly
now it's easy to think all this
technology and capability will mean a
bigger console but again we wanted more
not only have we built the most powerful
console ever Xbox one X is the smallest
Xbox ever
this is the system you asked us to build
and it has been a great honor to design
and build it for you
I couldn't be more proud of our team and
I hope you love it as much as we do now
let's see what this monster can do
exclusive world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome from the ports of racing
franchise Dan Greenawalt
[Music]
in the automotive world supercars are
debuted at international auto shows
Frankfurt Paris Detroit but through your
passion for racing on Xbox and PC Forza
has become the premier partner to the
automotive industry so today for the
first time in history a flagship
supercar is making its world debut here
at e3 in front of you this year we
announced a six-year partnership with
Porsche to bring you amazing experiences
both in game and in person Porsche
shares our vision for the future of
racing and eSports and this car has
never been seen outside of the guarded
walls of Porsche that honor belongs to
you exclusively ladies and gentlemen may
I present the 2018 Porsche 911 gt2 RS
[Music]
this is not only the most aggressive
expression of porcius legendary design
it features the most powerful road-going
911 engine ever made like the xbox 1x
it's a monster and with over 4.8 million
active players across Xbox and Windows
10 Forza is one of the largest racing
communities on the planet
you made this historic moment possible
through your passion for racing the
digital and the real worlds are merging
in an unprecedented way so now let's
take a look at the Porsche 911 gt2 RS in
Forza Motorsport 7 running on Xbox one X
I'm joined on stage by two presenters
for our fourth racing championship
eSport series
I'm Shannon Mackintosh professional
racecar driver and Porsche driving coach
I'll be pushing the gt2 RS to its limits
on the sun-baked streets of Dubai and
dine Farina may professional racer and
stud driver I will be fighting to
survive dynamic weather in the
Nurburgring in this Nissan gt-r race car
we start with Shannon and her customized
driver on do by using the power of Xbox
one X quarts of motorsport seven runs at
a native 4k and a rock-solid 60 frames
per second and we have the additional
power to deliver shocking slow levels of
detail using super high res lap
resolution assets we've recreated the
intense feel of one of the greatest
driving roads in the world
the habib mountain pass
but in for Tamar's 47 we've reimagined
the entire racing experience on all
devices racing is more immersive and
dynamic ominous skies roll in as car
parts rattle and vibrates we've made
racing more epic and grand race through
living environments featuring
spectacular vistas and massive scale you
can see we made racing more dynamic and
surprising dynamic pummels grow as the
storm unleashes its fury
it's more thrilling and competitive feel
the intense heat grease up your tires as
you battle your rivals and it's more
beautiful and alive dark skies open up
and change as the Sun emerges from the
clouds for a breathtaking finish
[Music]
[Applause]
Racing is reborn in port so whether
running on the Xbox one family of
consoles or Windows 10 pcs Fortson
Motorsports 7 is the most technically
advanced and comprehensive racing games
ever made with more than 700 cars it
features the largest collection of
Lamborghinis Ferraris and Porsches ever
assembled today you were the first
people to see the 2018 Porsche 911 gt2
RS in this week at e3 like me you can be
the first to drive it so come experience
the most powerful road-going 911 ever
made on the Xbox one X the most powerful
console ever made in Forza Motorsport 7
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm going to play a ton of Forza
Motorsport 7 when it ships on October
3rd and when Xbox 1x launches we will
all get to experience
Fortson motorsports 7 in true 4k at 60
frames per second today we're going to
showcase the world's greatest creators
with a lineup of different types of
games for every type of gamer it is the
largest and I believe the most diverse
lineup of games that we've ever shown on
our Xbox III stage games from creators
large and small games that inspire and
challenge us games that transport us to
new worlds and offer us new perspectives
and games that push the boundary of our
art form today we will feature 42 games
here on our stage including 22 games
with console exclusivity on Xbox one
every one of these games will play great
on each member of the Xbox one family
but of course they will play best on
Xbox one X up next is a game from a
creative team that built their franchise
on Xbox in 2010 for a games worked with
us to launch a single-player masterpiece
that I played on xbox 360 now I'm
honored to bring them back with the
premiere of their next work running in
engine in true 4k
world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
world premiere we are the first the
first to see the gods
the first to tame their beasts
[Music]
the first to guard the soul from evil
[Music]
we conquered this land and built an
empire
but there are whispers on the wind a
brotherhood or need the shadows
they are the first to call themselves
the assassins
[Applause]
remove Assad creative director Zhang and
all
[Music]
you
thank you ancient Egypt is the
birthplace of modern civilization and it
is also the birthplace of the assassins
Brotherhood Assassin's Creed origins is
taking you to the perfect setting for an
epic gaming adventure Egypt 3,000 years
of history and mystery at the tip of
your fingers sanskrit origins is also
the story of one man by ik by ik is the
last magi the protector of his community
an egyptian sheriff if you like and
struggle against the dark forces that
corrupt ancient egypt we live to the
foundation of the assassins brotherhood
which recreating ancient egypt going
back so far in time pushed us to rethink
and expand our gameplay mechanics we
added many RPG elements to a huge
systemic world more detailed and alive
than ever before so today we are very
proud to show you what the game looks
like on x bond why xbox one x running in
4k and now just for you
byuk is coming back to see WA his home
town to kill the fake Oracle madryn
amman world premiere
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah sirrah my home the sacred oasis
Oh
be my eyes salut
this temple resembles a fortress what
has happened
there you are madam on the next masked
one on my list
now it is my time to tip the balance of
Anubis
we have broken
you better be careful here
I should repeat that not a Santa
uh fine bow
good
the purpose lead is dead please they
will surely before it is too dangerous
we pass for now
guide me soon met una moon
you will die I do not wanna die
see what is mine
finally
[Music]
at Xbox we've always believed in the
power of games to unite us all today
communities of gamers not only play
together they create together and watch
together a whole new genre of games has
emerged design for both the player and
the community and with mixer we're
innovating new features to make these
experiences even better this one's
special of all the games in this genre
here is one that the world is having as
much fun watching as they are playing
and I can tell you that includes many of
us a team Xbox the creative director of
player unknowns battlegrounds is a gamer
turned developer who designed this game
together with a passionate community
please welcome player unknown himself
Brendon Greene
[Applause]
thanks Phil good afternoon everyone
player unknowns battlegrounds is a
multiplayer battle royale where you must
fight against a hundred other players to
be the last one standing our team's
focus is to bring the most complete
battle royale experience ever to console
and deliver a great experience across
all Xbox one devices our development is
truly community driven and we are much
of our success to everyone who's given
us feedback over the past year with over
three million PC players to date we
can't wait to bring player unknowns
battlegrounds exclusively to Xbox one
later this year with an update for Xbox
1x enhancements shipping with the final
version see you on the battleground
everyone exclusive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
exclusive destroy no heroics
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
exclusive
[Music]
what would you do
if the world you knew
who's gone all the comforts
the simple pleasures you took for
granted how would you protect yourself
and the ones you love when the
protectors can't even save themselves
pull it out come on
[Music]
last truck get in
[Music]
how will you decide who belongs Thanks
how will you choose a place to call home
how will you build it
[Music]
walk together to defend it from the
terror
just outside the walls
[Music]
and you get hungry cold what risks will
you take what mistakes
will you make and the only family you've
got is about to tear itself apart will
you end a life wait or save it please
this is our only one we need everybody
we've got
you get into deep realize no one gets a
second chance
how will you find the strength to carry
on
[Music]
[Music]
in this world of the living and the dead
how will you survive
[Music]
exclusive
two players remaining
one player remaining I play when the
Wounded Warrior she was kinda Travis
used superior tactics to get herself on
in there she's got to take the win let's
move on to the next arena here we're
following bloody marrow there's only two
players left in this particular map
those tracks are leading up but that
tree is going to give them direct
information that red outline is immortal
unicorn and he's loading it about a
hundred meters away now looks like you
might be crafting or something but what
is this that bloody marrow is gonna do
getting ever closer join that beeline
and now he's gonna cloak it up if you
get a walk in through the front door or
what it looks like it's gonna sneak in
on the back window here we go shot the
bag that's one point bottles in trouble
somebody from mixer decided to chime in
that impulse ability bubbles going to
help them and put on the fighters life
there we go the nice drink of bloody
room bouncing on four and there we go oh
that was in the arrow to the belly
that's gonna be the way from lady-girl
bloody barrel wins the round
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome from ou yang brand
director Lydia winters
this summer
millions of Minecraft players will be
able to play together on the device of
their choice for the first time Xbox
Live will unite the global Minecraft
community across mobile VR Windows 10
pcs and consoles as part of this effort
we're excited to welcome player made
skins Maps textures and massive
community run servers into the game
itself because we know that the amazing
content you create makes minecraft even
better this fall minecraft will receive
a free 4k update that brings more
graphical options to the game but we
didn't stop there with all this talk
about graphics we're taking things one
step further today
we're revealing a new look for Minecraft
that we're super duper excited for you
to try out one that's inspired by the
power of Xbox one X and available this
fall let's check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
minecraft in 4k when the Minecraft team
showed me the first version of the game
in 4k I was blown away mo yang is a
great example of a studio that started
something new and different that led to
a global phenomenon at Xbox we're
searching for games that are fresh new
and in some cases familiar that means
ensuring that the biggest third-party
franchises you want to play are there
for you on Xbox one
of course you'll find these great games
in the Xbox Store available for
pre-order today but bringing the biggest
blockbuster franchise is just one part
of the job delivering broad diverse and
new games to Xbox means searching to
find unique games from creators around
the world that will surprise and delight
to me these next few games do just that
starting with the game I got to play on
a recent trip to Japan it's hilarious a
little crazy and a whole lot of fun
let's take a look at it world premiere
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
exclusive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
exclusive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
exclusive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
we've scoured the globe meeting with
creative artists and development teams
and I'm often surprised and humbled by
their work whether it's a story that can
only be born of a different land or
artistic design and storytelling that in
a single moment can capture your
imagination and inspire there is much to
be learned by looking beyond borders our
first party is also a place of
innovation and creativity today I'm
excited to share with you an extended
look at never-before-seen gameplay from
rare shared world adventure see if
theives exclusive
[Music]
the joy of a new voyage far across the
sea of thieves just you the wide open
world at Obama's not just you she's here
too oh and this guy's here but the point
is this is a shared world right for
exploring and reading with your fine
pirate crew
welcome scurrying around making
themselves useful that's what we like to
see the world of sea of thieves seeds
with possibilities with adventures
skulking above and below the waves all
you have to do is jump in and up there
she goes
[Music]
few things tempt a pirate like the siren
song of a lootable shipwreck careful
there could be anything down there
literally there could be anything we
haven't finished designing it yet joking
that was a joke ah sunken treasure it's
like a pirate performance sports
[Applause]
every players decisions and discoveries
will be different but however you plan
on seeking your fortune it pays to be
prepared for gigantic lumps of iron
these are surprisingly portable amazing
workmanship enemy bear get them back on
board while the coast is clear there's
really no sense in pushing your luck
down here that is not a beast you want
to pick a fight with yes it's possible
to take on these two thee't errors of
the deep you're not much used to your
crew getting into
[Music]
sometimes a tactical key is perfectly
acceptable in the spirit of that
legendary pirate captain pathetic Dee
[Music]
thankfully for every tense standoff
there's a moment of celebration or
shared wonder but for now
store your hard-earned loot and enjoy
the voyage on Devil's read beneath the
sands the gold lies hidden from thieving
hands no well that's typical look here
we are at Devil's Ridge nice transition
by the way
and so you shift from the heart of the
sea to the island shore where you'll
explore jungles and coves clef tops and
caverns every region has it's very own
landmarks and over time you'll uncover
hidden shortcuts abandoned stashes and
Vestas they'll steal your grog soaked
breath away and yes sometimes you'll
encounter people who for whatever reason
would like to blow you into little
pieces
that's pirating for you keep that pestle
pranked because you'll also face the
roaming remains of those Raiders who
came before you cut short in pursuit of
their own legends
and afterlife of waiting in trouble
McLean tell all your bets fall off it's
what it would have wanted
now make sure your crewmates all apart
to play yep that works and look they
brought the riddle map seek the cursed
borscht rain where there is no sky it
lies and wheat for a length held high
right well that's gotta be around here
somewhere but if you've got bad feeling
you can always leave someone on board to
brace the ship for a speedy galley
decisions decisions
ah looks like they've snuffed out that
place where there's no sky time to pull
your resources as you'd plunge into the
unknown
it would be easy to come a cropper in
these claustrophobic caves you don't
want to wander off track unless of
course you're streaming I know the loads
of people in the chat telling you what
to do anyway
[Music]
don't man is probably nothing just kids
of course the premier plunder isn't just
lying around to be clean by any old
drunken bum block you'll need to watch
out for likely locations following your
map clues and your instincts to make a
light work of each new mystery
late work well Lantern joke there you're
welcome
anyway step 11 paces Northwest through
the gloom beg my chest from its tomb and
with that we're one step closer to
payday
then again some of the loot in these
parts has lain undisturbed for a long
long time that has to be the spot you
can practically taste the treasure good
call on a double duty shovel work to
that store mate says was nipping at your
heels ah very nice
of course the trouble with treasure as a
rule is that the owners really like to
hang on to if you put your hand school
it's up to your crew to watch your back
and while they're doing that it's paying
for another strategic withdrawal with
the loot
[Music]
nope no Matt wait that's it easy now
[Music]
don't stop keep going almost there watch
that next step is it easy no that's a
rescue
[Music]
maybe you can regularly beat the odds
and get chess back to your ship you'll
be able to turn a tidy profit by trading
the men and outpost that's just their
tiny matter of making it through this
storm in one piece
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all pirate life is here on the sea of
things and you can let viewers however
you want so rally your crew
st. seal for riches and infamy become a
pirate of legend
just try not to be this one
exclusive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
exclusive world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
exclusive
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
exclusive [ __ ] they killed the
power around the world we're gonna light
it back up because this is far from over
in fact it's only just begun that's why
we brought in you you got to tell her
now you need the day you throw a grenade
Oh tomorrow you'll be throwing cars
forget dropping bombs you drop it
building now it's time to get to work
time to step up
oh yeah
[Music]
determination to conquer all my
ambitions ready to this position and so
my disposition
[Music]
[Applause]
some people never have trouble that's
why they don't know what the struggle is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
this is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know you can't stop
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
at Xbox it's not just about finding
creative artists it's about empowering
them and nurturing them helping shine a
light on their work making it easy for
them to build and share their creations
that's why the idea Xbox program is so
important to us the team has released
over 500 games on Xbox one and Windows
10 through the ID at Xbox program and
this is not just a milestone for the
program and the independent developer
community it's a milestone for everyone
who loves great games I hope you're
reminded today why it's so great to be a
gamer on Xbox action adventure story
skill surprise these next few games
bring it all together let's start with
the game whose stylistic approach alone
makes it something very special
exclusive
[Applause]
[Music]
the dark is older than the light
at last a day dawned and we rose with
this first light but that light was a
betrayal only fleeting
in its wake the night returns blame us
after lifetimes the light grows again
faint and vulnerable
[Music]
rather than just survive in the dark
this rebirth will end our wandering
world premiere
[Music]
follow me home pretend you
[Music]
found somebody to hand you
[Music]
I feel now I feel numb in this kingdom I
feel numb I feel numb in this king
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Rachel
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome from monolith productions
vice president of creative michael de
platter
me you progr you mili ate me he left
your mark on me but anything work you
burned my mind dark I'll kill you until
this moment you have not known suffering
I'll write another your mouth bruise so
now I'm gonna kill you for all these
orcs to see Oh
I said you were an optimist know what
that is mate
it's about sizing up a situation that's
bloody impossible and saying here on
I'll have a go on exactly the same way
I like him
Cruz killed the boss come on in shadow
of Mordor we introduced a way to create
unique personal stories for every player
and in shadow of war we're expanding the
Nemesis system to new features we're
really excited about forging an army of
followers and nemesis fortresses here
we'll use the ring of power and recruit
this Olaf Brewster chopper to expand our
army then we're going to assault a
fortress control by one of sour odds
over lovers
oh that was nasty
breaker yokai to skewer may that little
swords good for a tickle maybe were you
gonna need more than that judge I'd made
out nice one Ranger
just never happened to me before
the right Lord now bright Lord our Lord
same thing really
it results me ripping spines out which I
like to do anyway so either ways a win a
fine addition to our man nice burst from
your now I will be your shadow no one
gets to you without my say-so
don't worry about my enemies it will all
follow eventually you want to apply your
flag in Mordor you'll need to do a deep
there's a fortress near boy ice at ruled
by a two-headed troll big as a mountain
deadly smart which Marcus he'd have to
be given the two heads
you taken down you sent a message to
Sauron anchor yourself some nice new
digs as part of the bargain we're not
going to do this alone gather your
troops will do up just make sure you MA
poppies heads off words yeah
[Music]
so we already have a few loyal followers
in our army and recruiting booth means
we're ready to assault the fortress and
overthrow the overlord we're enormous ly
expanding the open-world of Mordor to
new regions like Sarah Gaston Kira
Thunder models a massive living
breathing world filled with orc society
tribes and wildlife as well as stories
and secrets you grieve me in to any
other or would have died but I survived
more than that I thrived my brothers put
me back together stronger than ever but
they didn't make me into what I am you
jeet you created the machine
push final machine he's trapped if
across Mordor seeking vengeance he's one
of the seven you are crimes without any
knew she was rider to finally
you disorder the steel
instead of killing the machine will
dominate his manner we can take
advantage of his abilities during the
florges assaults you took out the
Overlord before we charge headfirst into
battle we should plan our attack and
select our followers
[Music]
[Applause]
colonel he look those rocket Aggies
sighs ever came
mudlick speech is a little rusty exelon
arcing wood which is a pine in the
aspect that hazard a case he said you're
all gonna die horribly yeah mark on a
black well I will handle the overlord
you focus on the defenders to fine focus
[Applause]
there are unlimited ways to forge your
story in conquer mode or in shadow of
war and we can't wait to show you more
this week at e3 thank you very much
exclusive world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Auri affirms my belief in the beauty
artistry and heart within the art of
gaming we believe that games like books
movies and music should be celebrated
and enjoyed by countless generations
we're passionate about preserving and
celebrating the games you own the
classics of the past and the genres you
love to play that's why two years ago we
launched the xbox backward compatibility
program to bring Xbox 360 games to your
Xbox one and we've seen tremendous
growth in the program today our library
of games stands at 385 titles and over
half of Xbox one gamers have played a
backward compatible game but I've heard
your feedback and you want more today
I'm pleased to announce an exciting
expansion to the program
our team of engineers are working hard
to bring us some of your favorite
original xbox game to today's Xbox one
library including a fan favorite that
I'm asked about often by the community
crimson skies and it looks great and
like the Xbox 360 games og games Lua
look better and play better across the
Xbox one family we'll have more to share
about this program when it launches
later this year I'm proud of the library
of games available today on Xbox one
all of them will benefit from the
performance and power when you play them
on Xbox one X but we won't stop there
I'm excited announce that if you own
Gears of War 4 forts of horizon 3 killer
instinct Halo Wars 2 or minecraft will
providing 4k updates to these titles for
free
and we already have over 30 titles from
our third-party partners that are
planning to provide free updates as part
of our Xbox 1x enhanced program titles
like Final Fantasy 15 Resident Evil 7
Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon wildlands and
rocket League just to name a few
this means you probably already have a
large library of titles that you own
today that will automatically get better
on Xbox 1x today we showcase some of the
world's greatest creators with a lineup
of different types of games for every
type of gamer we showed you the largest
and most diverse lineup of new games
that have ever appeared on our stage
from every corner of the globe
from developers large and small 42 games
including 22 with console exclusivity on
Xbox one and you're also going to be
able to play all of the biggest
cross-platform blockbusters on Xbox one
and every game will play great across
the Xbox one family and on Xbox one X
runs every single game you've seen even
better so if you haven't joined the Xbox
one family now's the time this week
you'll find Xbox 1s available in the US
for $249 and on November 7th will begin
worldwide rollout of Xbox one X the
world's most powerful console at $4.99
be the first to experience unrivaled
power and performance on the Xbox one we
close today's show by looking to the
future with a really great partner
they've been with us from the earliest
days of Project Scorpio
and they're building an incredible game
that takes advantage of the power and
performance of the Xbox one family and
the new Xbox one X please welcome
Patrick Sutherland executive vice
president EA worldwide studios
[Applause]
[Music]
new IP is the lifeblood of our industry
it's also risky at ei we have teams
streaming up a lot of projects and only
the greatest will make it their way to
you and that's okay it's all a part of
the creative process and it's worth it
because when you find something special
there is no better feeling as a
developer than introducing players to a
brand new world and as a player there's
no better feeling than losing yourself
in a completely new experience our
developers of Bioware have been creating
something truly special a huge open
world that is lush savage mysterious and
ever-changing filled with interesting
characters and new types of gameplay
you'll enjoy with your friends for years
to come
this is what's possible we take an
extraordinary vision and combine it with
the latest technologies and hardware
amazing concepts become possible great
ideas become reality so here we are and
we are so excited to share this with all
of you on behalf of the team at Bioware
let's see what this game looks like
running on an Xbox 1x here's John Warner
from Bioware to show you anthem
[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm John Warner game director for
anthem here is the world premiere of
anthems gameplay
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
freelancer Braxley
listen trouble big trouble what did you
do mistake I hired some people they
weren't freelancers I know they said
they could handle it and the price was
right
I thought maybe unbelievable you're
right it was stupid
I'm sorry but they're still out there
somewhere if you could just bring them
back anything you need
in the world of anthem you and your
friends are freelancers the heroes who
leave the safety of the walls of port
Tarsus to explore the unknown and
protect humanity
let's join two players as they head out
on an expedition hey Bob you ready to go
just grab us with supplies just already
what are you gonna use today I decided
to go with the Colossus
I'm gonna use my ranger try out some new
upgrades
[Music]
every player will own an array of
exosuits we call javelins these suits
give players superhuman capabilities and
are heavily customizable so they look
and play how you want and looking good
nice you've got a mortar equipped yeah I
got on the weekend you lead the way
this is a vast open world you explore
with your friends
each javelin exosuit has its own unique
play style the Ranger is balanced in all
purpose while the Colossus is a tanking
powerhouse all right let's see what's up
here
the world of anthem is hostile and
threats can come from any direction
dynamic world was unexpected it's around
every corner yeah he seems like a
problem for another day
we require from the heaven although low
you flank
hang in there was there
have you been in there yeah
haven't I should do that later with Kim
you could use the XP
hello treasure
I think we got snacks you there
to attack anyone in the area we're under
attack
think that's part of Carson's mission
you can equip your javelin exosuit with
gear that brings devastating power to
combat oh there are a lot of scars down
there yeah all the scars have a heavy
time to use that hoarder need some
covering fire there's a bunch more
coming in okay I'll get this round
oh come on be something good
Oh Jerry's wrath oh nice large-scale
world events like shaper storms are
dynamic and pull you off the beaten path
with the promise of new stories to
discover Oh shaper storm incoming okay
actually let's get some more people hold
on a sec hey guys what's up hey what's
happening right behind you
this storm is getting crazy
so what are we supposed to do fly into
it alright let's do this
see on the other side
[Music]
our story is out there
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm coming
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]